all right we're now live for the AMA for
February 2024 uh looks like there's a
few new features in here that uh YouTube
is asking me to try which I'm not going
to this time since I don't know how
they're going to work so uh no questions
lined up quite yet but I'm sure they're
going to be coming in quickly so I'll
say oh there's one already but I'll I'll
say very quickly uh
trying out a new configuration there
were some issues in the last month on
YouTube's end some weird interference
with sound so hopefully we're not having
the crackly stuff going on that we did
before um I checked everything on my end
there wasn't much to to do about it so
might have been just a disturbance in
the interwebs all right so nerd wizard
what are the most important ethics that
you seek out in regard to the fictional
books you like or do you pick fiction
solely based on subject matter alone and
consider ethics only after reading so
neither um I I don't I don't uh read
fiction
Works saying well I want to read
something that's from a a utilitarian
perspective or you know a deontological
perspective or saying well I want
something that engages with this
particular area of Ethics I read the
fiction works that I do at least the new
ones because I'm interested in seeing
what that author has to to offer and
I'll say I don't get to read a lot of
stuff just like wandering around the
library and picking books off the shelf
like I did as a much younger person uh
instead it's usually for the world's of
speculative fiction or somebody's
recommended a particularly good author
or book to me um and now ethics you know
often does play in
into um fiction stuff in important ways
you know you could think about for
example somebody like
dostoevski who is particularly
interesting because you know he's got
these characters who are are grappling
with serious issues right um one of the
books that I like the best is actually
translated as the demons or the
possessed because there's so many
different ethical points of view that
are expressed in
arguments or in like monologues or
dialogues between the characters I mean
Notes from Underground has that as well
of course parts of um Brothers K maof
and you know fear and and Punishment and
things like that um you know but there's
so much great speculative fiction in
which there's interesting ethical issues
raised as well I will sometimes if I'm
teaching an ethics class class you know
like for example I'll often start my
students off on um Ursa Kaya greens uh
those who walk away from omalos to get
discussion going and I'll probably
supplement it with enk gon's those who
stay in fight when I do future classes
as well um so it's it it's not like I
you know approach fiction in a
programmatic way I like to see what's
actually in the fiction and you know and
good stuff like Philip K dick or you
know um well I you know I've been doing
this stuff on Stephen Ericson's maleson
novels great stuff for for thinking
about ethical issues in in that as well
all right um Mohamad says your thoughts
on Jean Luke Mario well I've actually
met the
guy and my engagements with him uh on a
personal level have not been I would say
particularly line with his philosophy
which stresses the importance of Charity
and love and Justice and stuff like that
it was a little
unedifying um I think that his work as a
historian of philosophy is
interesting um I you know view him as a
little bit too precious at times in how
he's treating particular topics and so I
spent a lot of time reading his work
back in the 90s s and early 2000s and
really don't spend much time with his
work now at all
um Sunny asks do you or have you ever
kept a journal for and in your own time
and interests if so why or why not yeah
I've I've done journaling in the past I
don't find journaling anywhere as useful
as I think a lot of people do and that's
not you know necessarily a reflection on
journaling because um you know different
things work for different people I find
that if I do write things in journals I
typically don't go back to it and it
winds up being a bit of a waste of time
I could just like think to myself about
that but I think a lot of people really
do find journaling quite
helpful um and I I could say that I've
certainly enjoyed writing stuff down
from time to time but most of the time
I'm not really writing things anymore
just from myself I'm writing it for
other people and you know maybe part of
that is the fact that time is shorter
you know I'm 53 years old so I'm
definitely past the halfway point of my
life unless I live
to6 which you know frankly seems pretty
doubtful um not a lot of people make it
into their 90s although I've got some
relatives in my past who have so there's
hope right um but you also have to kind
of you know keep your marbles too so I I
just don't I don't get that much out of
it so all right um also is there any
philosophical examinations of horror out
there yeah there's plenty of um
philosophers or people who are
philosophically oriented writing about
the genre of horror a simple Google
search will bring up tons but I'll just
mention a few people off hand
so you know there is the horror writer
Thomas lagotti who has a book a
conspiracy against the human race which
is a non-fiction book right and in it he
is sort of exploring his own views and
his influences which are other horror
writers and talking about a lot of
different philosophers you know
schopenhauer n you know contemporary
Neuroscience stuff uh um and he also is
reflecting on the nature of horror in
that that book we did a um worlds of
speculative fiction session on him last
year so not that long ago and you know
there's I mean one person who comes to
mind right away who's been kind of a
darling uh years back when
object-oriented antology became the next
big thing is Graham Harmon who has a
book on Lovecraft but there's lots and
lots and lots writings out there and you
can even go back to Lovecraft he's got
this um what is it called the
supernatural in literature I'm leaving a
word out somewhere and he's you know a
lot of it is sort of just literary
criticism but he's got some speculations
on fear and storytelling and the role
that that plays and and I think if you
look around you'll find many horror
authors saying saying a lot about what's
going on in horror and they'll be doing
so in ways that are are pretty
philosophical right all right let's see
uh John says is there a question concept
topic or a problem in Plato's Works
which you think has been largely ignored
or which you think ought to be given
more attention in future thinking well
that's a good one
um yeah I mean I I did a a talk years
and years back when I was still living
in uh New York I went down to Felician
where my friend was the chair of the
philosophy department at the time before
Felician took its nose dive into
financial exigency and basically fired
everybody uh who was doing
philosophy and it was um about platonic
virtues what the hell are they you know
uh Plato presents it as if they're
particular forms or ideas you know uh
and that kind of works maybe for justice
but it's not quite so clear that that
works for courage or even for wisdom you
know so that's kind of a interesting
contested topic and um you know I think
that one of the things that happens in a
lot of platonic dialogues is that people
read them as if the main thing is to
uncover the AR arguments and assess them
and see whether they achieved the goal
that was set out so in the Mino can we
Define
virtue well yeah I mean Plato does think
we can Define virtue because he does so
in the Republic but in the Mino we
can't um but we do learn a lot of really
interesting things about virtue and the
virtues along the way don't we namely
that nothing is going to be good no good
thing is good without two of the virtues
being involved and governing them wisdom
and Justice and so they have a certain
priority over the other virtues right I
mean that's that's something we're
learning along the way or when you read
the fedo right oh it's really about
these arguments about the uh immortality
of the Soul well yeah it's about that
but it's also about what genuine courage
and Temperance look like philosophical
courage and Temperance and and about the
danger of myology which is similar to
misanthropy so there's lots and lots of
like little side
conversations in Plato's works that I
think are really quite interesting and
important and often get overlooked when
we're teaching or or talking about
Plato uh impulsive how would you
characterize your relationship with
different eras of haider's thought I
don't have a relationship with different
erors of haiger thought because I'm not
a hiigaran who has to worry about that
all that much um I will say that I'm
much more interested in earlier stuff
than in you know the stuff with the
so-called turning or Cara I don't think
it's as radical of a change as people
make it out to be um you know being in
time for me is you know the most
important work and I would say some of
the other stuff from that time like you
know fundamental concepts of metaphysics
what is
metaphysics you know a lot of his
lectures that he gives in the the 30s
are really important for me as well and
I do like things that come later right
some of the essays and talks and stuff
like that but um I'm more focused on the
the things that where haiger is like
working out the fundamental
ontology or where he's doing
interesting
interpretations of other philosophers
that's mainly what I'm going to haiger
for and I think that he has a lot of
great contributions to make it's
certainly unfortunate that he allowed
himself to be seduced by uh Nazism and
um you know certainly some of his things
like I mean if you read the black
notebooks there ain't any redeeming that
stuff but I I don't think that means we
have to like write off being and time or
anything like that
so all right uh that boy is doeski top
five dead or alive not even sure what
that means um are you asking
whether dovi is in my top five but top
five what um top five writers literary
thinkers so maybe you want to give a
little clarification about
that um oh orille great question here um
I think I skipped over a few and I'll
come back to those uh is there ever a
line where one could read too much in
quotes into something for example
strauss's theory of esoteric writing in
Maki I mean Strauss theory of esoteric
writing is already a little too much
whether it's makavelli or Spinosa or
Plato pick whoever you want because he's
found an idea that um is kind of
unconfirm and you can do all sorts of
stuff with it and becomes like a master
hermeneutic for stuff and you know
there's a lot of people convinced by it
but when I read it I'm like yeah I don't
think so you know and and I for me in my
eyes Strauss is less of a thinker
because of that I I actually you know I
I read Strauss and sometimes like with
hogra find him insightful about some
things as soon as he starts getting into
this you know exoteric esoteric thing my
eyes kind of glaze over and I'm no
longer really paying that much attention
to what he has to say because I kind of
you know I went through that stuff and
it doesn't really get you anywhere it's
more like a intellectual one-upmanship
so yeah there's there's plenty of things
where somebody is reading too much into
something
and sometimes it's a matter of too
exclusive of a focus on too little
literature you know I've said many times
before that I think that wienstein was
you know smart
philosopher could have been a much
better philosopher had he read more
widely you know um you get the
impression you know for example in
philosophical investigations that he
didn't read he didn't read Augustine
very attentively if he thinks that you
know the little snippet that he has is
the augustinian theory of language
you're like okay so you read a little
bit of confessions but I mean you didn't
read like on Christian doctrine clearly
because you wouldn't be saying these
things so I think there's there's
sometimes a lot of you know focusing too
narrowly and you know I kind of there's
an attitude sometimes in philosophy like
I just need to read this I just need to
read this I just need to read this if
you really want to know about a thinker
um and you actually like them why
wouldn't you read as much of their stuff
as you can and then you know kind of
compare and contrast it you know I'm
always like a little surprised by these
people who are Scholars on a particular
thinker and you can tell they haven't
read or it's been a very very long time
since they've read some of that
thinker's key texts you know because
you're like well this issue that you're
having I mean it's talked about over
here so you know that is a uh a good
question there
um let's see what I skipped over here oh
William Edwards just a loose thought
here can there be a just war after
nuclear Armament can you justly declare
war knowing that the preconditions for
justice might be at stake yeah I mean
we've been doing it uh plenty of the
time
um the just you know whatever conditions
we have for just war and there's like
you know variety of different theories
out there um the mere fact that there's
nuclear weapons sitting around doesn't
mean that like you can't have a just War
I mean if you start the war shooting off
nuclear weapons okay that's that's a
problem right um but you know to me
that's kind of a they're not really
connected with each other unless you
think that any war is like automatic or
most likely going to lead to a nuclear
um conflagration and you know the
evidence of since we've had nuclear
weapons is that ain't what happens
because nobody's been using them
so all right vegan sports bar did nich
and shayer think that ramont could be
overcome could you please elaborate on
n's con concept of forgetting wrongdoing
yeah both nich so friederick nche is the
one who you know he doesn't invent the
word but he kind of coins a new or
coalesces a new concept of ranton and
then Mo shayer has a wonderful short
little book on ramont where he takes
nich's Theory criticizes parts of it
tweaks other parts reinterprets it they
both think it can be overcome I mean
maybe you're asking if you find yourself
in ramont can you fix that about about
yourself or are you like poisoned and
you'll never be able to to get rid of it
and I would say that both n and shayer
say you can but it's going to require a
lot of work and change of perspective a
change of the heart you know so to speak
not just of the mind so an affective and
cognitive change and it does have to do
with um forgetting or letting go you
know one one original um Greek term
that's used uh we translate it as
forgive for example in the gospels and
it's also used in a few places in
Aristotle who does talk about
forgiveness usually Aristotle uses the
term Sun but he also uses a cognant of
this at least at one place a literally
to throw to Cast Away from oneself so in
in the gospels when Christ is saying
forgive for example in The Sermon on the
Mount he's actually saying throw it away
Let It Go um and N is um not a you know
he's not rejecting Christianity in its
entirety at every single point as a
matter of fact he's got a lot of things
to say quite positive about Christ and
about the church in various Works um
even though he does consider
Christianity platonism for the masses as
he it platonism is a bad thing for
n um so getting yourself to the point
where you actually can rise above the
crap that people are trying to impose on
you or throw at you that's important now
what's really important though when it
comes to that is that you're not faking
it right you're not lying to yourself
because that's characteristic of the
person of ranta they're like oh look how
well I turn the other cheek oh I've
turned it more often than you have not
like you dirty bastards over there who
don't turn the other cheek and you're
not Meek I mean this is the person of
ranton that n is targeting right and you
know we can think of all sorts of people
I think in our own lives or maybe we've
even been those people who use
forgiveness as a kind of weapon and by
the way n wasn't the first person to
realize this you can see discussion of
that in Astic Literature Like John
cassian's um
institutes uh book eight he where he's
talking about anger he talks about
people who pretend to forgive you know
but it's really another expression of
their anger we would call it passive
aggressivity U and I'm sure it's also in
his conferences as well so you know a
lot to be to be said there uh Ricky
points out when it comes to ethics and
politics Robert heinan had some good
points yeah many many authors I think we
could fit in
there all right
um let's see uh d boy clous in an
episode of The Sopranos a character says
that sart stole most of his insights
from haiger is this true well I would be
a little suspicious of anything that
you're finding in a TV show that
references philosophy because it's
usually um writers who maybe had a
philosophy class back when they were in
college and remember vaguely a few
things from it and then they want to
show how clever they are by putting it
in there and that was in fact a common
criticism of sart but I think all you
have to do is read John Paul sart and
Reed haiger to realize that it's fairly
groundless where where where sart is
taking something from haiger he says by
the way this concept is from haiger but
certainly haiger didn't view sart as a
imitator of him because he wrote this
thing called the letter on humanism
where he was like wow you and me Jean
Paul are really doing very different
things so you know I would be very
suspicious uh I would be as suspicious
of
um shows talking about philosophy and
these little blurbs as I would be of
some random guy at the bar spouting his
wisdom after a couple drinks you know so
yeah all right um greo has says have you
seen or read John John s's epicurian
book it got me started down the road of
reading epicurus any other thoughts on
more books on epicureanism I haven't
read it although you know John and I are
friends and colleagues he's been very uh
prolific lately and I'm actually um he
not only has a book on epicurus out but
he's got a book on Aristotle out that I
I want to check out as well and probably
review I've reviewed quite a few of John
su's Works
um and uh I want to have him on an ideas
that matter conversation because um he
like I while very interested in stoicism
certainly see the merits of other uh
ancient schools of philosophy as did
some of the stoics like Sena for example
right epicus the epicurian are basic
all crap and the aristotelians are kind
of crap because they're like them senica
is like hey wisdom is wisdom wherever we
find it so let's not throw the
proverbial baby out with the bath water
so no I haven't I haven't read that one
um I'm looking forward to to finding the
time to do that there are other books
out there on
epicureanism um there's how to be an
epicurian um I'm blanking on her name
but that came out
preco um heram Crespo has a really great
great short little book that's been out
for well over 10 years now at this point
that I have reviewed called tending the
epicurian garden and he's one of the
people who's an organizer for the
Society of Friends which is an online
organization but he also does meetups in
Chicago he's somebody else I'd like to
interview one of these days um reading
epicurus ain't going to take you long
because we basic Al have just uh you
know two lists of principal doctrines
and three letters and you know of course
the life of epicus and his will that are
preserved in diogenes Litas and you
could read all of that in an afternoon
and read so read it thoughtfully so
reading epicurus doesn't take you long
we actually have more epicurian
literature meaning literature about the
epicurian in the critics of the epicur
Ian like Cicero or plutar or sexus
empiricus than we do in actual epicurian
literature although you know these
Scrolls at herculin turns out that um
there's a lot of epicureanism in that
Library so maybe we'll find more of
epicurus's works that would be kind of
kind of cool right all right
um let's see Sunny says in general how
much experience do you have in the realm
of anti-natalist philosophy of life
whether contemporary or ancient as
distinct from nistic and pessimistic
philosophies of life I mean it's not
really distinct because generally anti-
natalists will be pessimists or neols so
you know I mean there isn't I think this
is a distinction without a big
difference um I'm pretty familiar with
it you know we have this guy heges
uh who I've actually done a video on um
that you can easily find um in in the
stuff on seric philosophy and there's
other authors here and there who Express
things like this I mean you can find
viewpoints like this in Sophocles in the
mouths of certain characters I've you
know obviously spent a lot of time with
schopenhauer right um and you know
there's there's other authors along the
way and I mentioned latti legat is an
anti-natalist isn't he you know that uh
conspiracy against the human race it's
one of those those books um I've never
found it attractive or particularly
intriguing um you
know there's there's this old joke and I
think it's in Odo Mard um one of his
short little books of
essays where he's talking about uh and I
think it's coming from Sophocles
somebody's like the best thing is not to
be born and then he's like well who the
hell does that ever happen to you know
and the idea
is what you're going to complain about
your own birth I mean you had to be born
in order to complain about it and find
it so so miserable and crappy and all of
that sort of stuff so there's you know
I'm not saying well that nullifies your
position or anything like that but
there's a little bit of of uh weirdness
to that right and then advocating oh we
shouldn't possibly bring a child into
this world that's a big leap of faith
that the world is really as crappy as
you you think it is you know so so I've
never really taken anti-natalism very
seriously uh Max says I was going back
through hume's inquiry on human
understanding I was curious to hear some
of your thoughts on what the gaps are on
hume's arguments against causality or
knowing
Powers well I mean I think that so it's
not a g but it's a blatant contradiction
at least in the inquiry and I I guess
it's also there in the treaties too so
you know hum makes this really
interesting convoluted argument that we
we never have an experience of of cause
and effect right we only have this
observation of constant
conjunction and then later on he will
say by the way human nature basically
the same everywhere every culture every
time you want to know something about um
Greeks and Romans just look at English
and French men of our day uh because
they're basically all being motivated by
the same you know fundamental drives and
desires and and passions and stuff like
that and when you read that you're like
whoa where did this come from if you
think that like we can't actually
observe anything about causes and
effects don't the passions and drives
and all that kind of fall under that and
are they really so constant across time
and where the hell would you get this
from so so there's that right that's
probably the most glaring thing staring
me in the face every time that I I read
it um because you know hum is right well
we don't even have to look at English
and Frenchman of his time we can just
look at Americans and Canadians of our
time or you know Indians and pakistanis
of our time or pick pick any any group
that you want right so that that strikes
me as a problem there
um I think
that you know Hume wants to
claim that we don't we don't ever have
any grasp of of what we've been
traditionally calling causality and it
seems to me that
okay maybe we could buy into an
attenuated version of his view that like
a lot of times we don't know really
what's going on but it seems too strong
of of an argument it takes away too much
stuff right so you know that's that's
what my thoughts on it typically end up
being I mean you could go the conscient
way you know I released that whole set
of videos uh just recently on K prola
where he's he's offering a solution
um not a solution that I'm like super
attracted to that we have you know these
a priori uh
synthetic uh whatever you want to call
them categories principles concepts of
both the understanding and reason and
that you know kind of well in
sensibility to and that you know
provides us with causality is just one
of those uh categories and you're like
oh I don't know about that that that
seems a little bit too fasile of a
solution to me but okay so there there
you go
um let's see here oh okay so Sara says
what do you think of John Dewey's
American pragmatism um I'm not very
attracted to it and it's in part because
I went to Southern Illinois University
for my graduate school for Masters and
PhD I spent seven years there and at
least at that time that was the place to
study John
Dewey why because there were two
professors out of the 14 or 15 that we
had who were Dewey experts one of the
big strengths at uh Southern Illinois
University was that it was a pluralistic
department so we had professors in
analytic philosophy we had professors in
continental and we had professors in
classical American philosophy which
includes Dewey and I'll tell you what
else we had as well and then we had a
few like uh history of philosophy people
as well and you know some some other
things but those were like the three big
divisions and so you got a lot of Dewey
all the time because a lot of The
Graduate students were there to study
Dewey we were a uh school that a lot of
students would come and they'd gotten
their masters at Texas A&M where they'd
study with like John locks and then they
came to study Dewey at Southern Illinois
University we also had the center for
Dewey studies which I actually worked
for for a semester doing research work
right it was a common uh research
assistant position and you read and hear
about Dewey in a lot of your classes I
have never been a fan um I think that
his writing is you know not very
clear um I think that he's what we could
call triumphalis about
pragmatism and a certain uh you know
sort of sciency American Progressive
thing um and he writes off way too much
stuff that he shouldn't have written off
you know it was very eye openening to be
sent to do
research uh on um Dewey and his
engagements during the Russell
controversy and to see how bigoted he
was against for example Catholics um and
not in a intelligent way just sort of in
a knee-jerk way and so that kind of
tarnishes the guy um there's other
pragmatists who I like better I like
William James William James is somebody
who I've been reading and teaching for
years and years and uh he's a little bit
earlier than
Dewey I think he's he's a better
philosopher
frankly um you know Charles purse is
kind of a you know an acquired taste
let's say um but he's an interesting guy
too and you know Josiah Roy um I like
him as well um I also do like you know
some earlier American philosophy the
transcendentalists and at Southern you
could study these these people and uh so
that was that was a real strength and so
I can say you know I don't dislike Dewey
uh for a superficial reason I got to
read Dewey and I got to see what people
who call themselves Deans looked like
and um how they how they you know
comported the themselves in life
and very often it wasn't very edifying
you know so I'm not not a big fan of of
him um Dre says I try to separate a
person from their Works to avoid ad
hominum but I often wonder if in some
cases like haiger I'm missing something
when I take too seriously his arguments
when he ended up as Nazi well I mean
that's kind of a silly thing to do um
you can take anybody's arguments
seriously regardless of what their
political orientation is I mean Plato
hated democracy you're going to write
off Plato because of that um you know
Aristotle thought that uh women uh were
naturally inferior to men and had less
teeth uh you're gonna write off
Aristotle for stupid things he says
about women that that's it's not a good
way to to do things I I think you know
Kant says a lot of boneheaded things you
know um if you if you masturbate you're
basically you know abusing Humanity in
yourself right um there's all sorts of
interesting commitments where we often
do want to say well here's what I like
about these philosophers or philosopher
or School here's what I think is you
know kind of kind of off maybe even evil
you know and you can you can hold two
ideas in your head at the same time so
you know that's what I I would
suggest um Germaine says I'd like to be
reading Hegel mainly his practical
philosophy do you have any
recommendations on where to begin H
hegel's very difficult
um I mean if you're interested in
hegel's Practical philosophy which would
include ethics and politics and stuff
like that the the main book is the
philosophy of right right which is a you
know much later work um you know be
prepared for some jargon and stuff like
that but I I actually think the
philosophy of right is a easier read
than say the phenomenology of spirit or
let alone the science of logic there are
parts of the um the phenomenology that
are devoted
to ethics and morality and all that and
it's this developmental thing and I I've
been meaning to go back to the the
discussions that he has in the morality
section which I think are really quite
quite good you know but um it's often
hard to follow that kind of stuff there
is this early work called the system of
ethical life that might be of interest
and you can kind of see you know some
outlines of some of the things that are
in both the phenomenology and the
philosophy of right in that U but
there's no one single place really to go
right um and I always say if you're
going to try to dig in Hegel in a
substantive way maybe the two books to
start with instead of starting with the
phenomenology are the lectures on the
philosophy of History which does have
some you know important practical stuff
in there he's sort of charting out
freedom is like what is being developed
through time and then the lectures on
the uh history of philosophy because
you'll have read some of these other
philosophers so you get to see what
Hegel is doing with them and you kind of
take on his his take right and he's also
engaging with other people's Ethics in
there you
know so
um I think I might have missed something
earlier let me just scroll back up
because I thought there was something
about
eclecticism uh but maybe I'm Maybe I'm
Wrong okay so or it got the question got
withdrawn all right
um Tom says what philosophy of Life do
you find most helpful for you in your
personal life I don't have a philosophy
of life that I find most helpful for me
in my personal uh life I am an Eclectic
so I draw upon
multiple Traditions schools movements
whatever you want to call them so I can
tell you the ones that are big for me
you know um the three great early
schools of virtue ethics platonic
Aristotelian stoic you know and platonic
doesn't just mean reading Plato it means
reading Plutarch it means reading alenis
these middle platonist figures and then
later platonist figures as well some of
whom are pagans like uh you know um
platinus some of whom are uh Jewish like
uh filo of Alexandria and some of whom
are Christian like uh most of the church
fathers you know so that's you know
important for me um existentialist
philosophy you know that I draw quite a
few of those people some dialectical
philosophy
and you know kind of Pierce this stuff
together I mentioned that I really like
William James he's become more and more
important to me as time has gone on as
well but I don't have a single
philosophy of life and I've gone through
phases which I think can be quite useful
for people in their development where I
was like I can say I am a sartan or I am
a nitian and I'm trying to live it out
you know through Reading their texts and
applying it and reflecting on my
experience and living that way but I
came out of all of that um as a
pluralist or an Eclectic thinking that I
I I need to bring together a bunch of
different voices some of whom are more
useful at some time some of whom are at
other times
so and I I would suggest you know I
don't I want to say I don't want to say
every body has to be that way I'd be
kind of a hypocrite as a pluralist if I
were to do that but it can be something
useful to take off your shoulders this
assumption that it's really really
important to find a one single point of
view and then stick to that exclusively
so all right Sunny uh biological
reductionism was rampant in my
psychology degree many professors would
consider human conscious experience even
down to the most idiot syncratic qualia
was ultimately material uh in your view
How likely is it that human psychology
human thought and behavior has an
entirely natural biological origin that
were purely physical systems I mean I I
would actually say I don't even know
what the hell a purely physical system
is and neither do they that's an
abstraction from from our experience you
know and the better writers out there
who are you know thinking about these
sorts of things will say similar stuff
you know obviously there's a material
basis to things but does that mean
everything can be reduced to like you
know uh essentially quantifying and
measuring and you know the theories that
we have about those sorts of things I
mean every time somebody tries to put
forth something like that getting away
from like Atomic physics but you know
about like human beings and their
emotions what they do ends up being kind
of laughable you know um you look at all
these attempts to provide these very
redu
explanations of stuff and they they run
out their usefulness real real quick you
know and you're like why do you believe
in this stuff I mean you make fun of
other people for believing in some sort
of like Airy fairy schh Soul or you know
God way above in the sky that looks like
an old guy with a beard but you're bu
buying into stuff that's just as silly
you know you just dress that up in
pseudo scientific stuff that you know a
couple Generations later people will
identify as as pseudo science so that
that'd be my my response hey Mark uh
Mark
says been reading into philosophy of
Technology lately and found your videos
on heiger great for making sense of gell
what are some thinkers you'd recommend
for making sense of a digital public
sphere and why oh okay well I
mean you know and I'm not I'm not
original in pointing this out i' I've
seen many other people pointing this out
but
kard um his the present age is really
quite preent uh in thinking
about um some of the stuff that happens
once we have this thing we call the
internet although you know he's writing
long before that right but it's it's
kind of useful for that um I think that
you know authors who think about us as
beings that modify ourselves that
essentially make ourselves into
Technologies in a certain way can be
useful so you know for who has this
concept of Technologies itself but of
course he's getting that from much
earlier authors n is somebody who thinks
of us in that way as well you know um so
you know they they they might be useful
obviously there's there's plenty of
people in recent times who have been
theorizing about
media some
more uh
deeply than others you know so for
example when I say that I'm willing to
bet a lot of people's minds go to
Marshall mclen And the tagline the
medium is the message if you actually
read Marshall mcclan who's I would say
you know a great second rate thinker uh
he's not he's not First Rate by any
means um you want to read the guy that
he references all the time Walter on who
was a Jesuit scholar who was very very
interested in and orality and writing
and Technologies you know um I would say
that you know the emphasis on on
communication and media can be quite
useful for that so there's there's like
just tons and tons of writers out there
who you might um look up and and make
sense out of and you know when you talk
about the public
sphere I just thought of this I mean
somebody who's been Contin ually writing
and responding to changes in things and
who has a great early work the what is
it called the development of the
[Music]
um it's not the public sphere habas
right Juran hos is somebody who
certainly deserves a seat at the table I
guess we could say right
so all right Elijah says Blondell
differs from
kard it just scrolled down a bit uh here
we go and believing man is a compacity
for transcending his own imminence how
can their mappings of the forms of
awareness be put into dialogue to apply
both in life specifically how can the
concept of anxiety or sickness onto
death be put into dialogue with action
volume two I don't know I haven't read
action volume two for a very long time
so I can't answer that um but what I can
say is yeah blown Dell is is different
from kard in a lot of ways and similar
to kard in a lot of ways and you know uh
kard was becoming kind of a big thing in
France in the 30s at the time that
Blondell is not really reading that much
because his eyes don't work anymore and
he's doing things basically by having
books read to him and by dictation to
his
secretary um but he would certainly the
circles he's moving in you know with
theud philosop they're talking a lot
about kard at that that time in the 30s
um you know I think that that one of the
issues with
kirkgard that is very problematic but is
not irresolvable and and you know
kirkgard Scholars have talked a lot
about this in the last say 20 years is
kirkgard seems to focus too much on the
individual and on the inability to
communicate the you know the religious
as separate from the ethical or the
aesthetic um and Blondell in his works
is trying to restore sort of a not Unity
but connections between these these uh
different Realms there's a greater
possibility for human communication to
actually work for
Blondell you can easily fall into all
sorts of things that kard calls
topair and you know Blondell is
identifying things like that in his his
works I mean one of I I don't want to
get too far into this because um
Blondell is such a complex thinker
there's so many ideas at work but um one
of the things that you can say is
blondell's Method whether it's the early
method of imminence or the later method
of
implication is you take a position
and then you say okay let's go with this
where let's you know unfold it this is
why Blondell is also a phenomenologist
even though he doesn't use the word
phenomenology um let's let's approach it
in charity and give it as much space
within ourselves and see what actually
results from it um and you know Blondell
ends up taking on um what kirkgard is
calling Despair and identifying and you
know sort of um differentiating in
sickness onto death and in other
places um in in at various points in his
work and he you know we can feel anxiety
when we're doing philosophy and that can
be quite important in motivating what it
is that we're we're doing all right
um vegan Sports board you have a short
reading list for someone in ramont
wanting to do the work on changing the
heart not only the mine I don't have a
short reading list um could I come up
with one well yeah I mean we've
mentioned n and shayer so definitely
they would be in there and you know you
would want you know if you want to think
about rant month probably the two best
books uh for n would be um genealogy of
morals where he's actually looking at
that quite um extensively but also I
would say Beyond Good and Evil would be
a good complement to that shaylor's
essay on ramont um but if you want to
think more broadly there's a nice volume
and I forget exactly what it's called
but it's like shayer on feeling loving
knowing I think
[Music]
um where it's it's kind of un unpacking
um what he calls the heart there's a lot
of essays in there that could be be
valuable
um and then who else would be good for
thinking about that I think earlier
authors you know when they're
considering similar
issues so somebody who I think you know
might be um
useful is blae
Pascal you know and thinking about one
of the ideas that he has um is that we
need to and Blondell by the way does
this too we need to not throw away um
what appear to be opposed ideas we need
to make the space needed for different
things so that we don't become as he
calls it tyrannical expecting everything
to fit into one um mold um I think some
of the early Christian
authors that maybe n doesn't like so
much but shayer does like like Augustine
could be quite quite helpful for this as
well but it's not something that I've
you know thought about putting um a
reading list together on um that could
be kind of an interesting Prospect I
suppose um the Rabid cow have you
engaged with any of Oliva blanchett's
philosophical work I encountered a
recommendation to read his book of
philosophy of being from David Bentley
Hart I've not only engaged with oliv a
blanchett's philosophical work met him
and had conversations with him at the uh
uh St
anel uh conferences uh the metaphysics
colloquia that they used to have well
they still do have them I I haven't been
going to them so that's that's the part
that's changed and Blanchett has died so
obviously we're not having any more
conversations unless he comes back from
the dead to to visit me and there's many
more people he's probably if he's going
to do that it wouldn't be to visit me
right it'd be to visit his students um
yeah I mean I actually had a
correspondence with him back when I was
writing my dissertation on Maurice
Blondell in part because you know he he
is the translator the second translator
of locko 1893 and so I wrote him to ask
him why did you retranslate the book and
he said well I was teaching it in my
classes at Boston College and James
somerville's translation is so crappy
there was it Summerville yeah I think it
was uh that I kept having to like make
Corrections and I was like I just better
translate this myself you know and so we
went back and forth and I asked him
about various things and I've read
articles that he's written I actually
reviewed for uh I think it was Catholic
University of America press um his
latest
translation of the uh demands of the
Christian religion translation of
blondell's late Works um and I reviewed
his
Monumental um biography it's over a
thousand pages on Maurice Blondell a
philosophical life and I've read
articles of him here and there so yeah I
mean I I like I like Blanchett I think
he's he's a great thinker um and he was
certainly somebody very devoted to to
Lone
Dell all right um Tom do you find any
validity in the philosophy of Carl Mars
yeah just like I find validity in a lot
of people's philosophy I mean why
wouldn't there I mean you'd have to be
really really extraordinary to write
works a philosophy that had zero
validity in any of the ideas whatsoever
you know um I mean plenty of criticisms
can be made of marks and there's plenty
of things that where he seems to be you
know pretty pretty on point you
know uh also I've been reading the
thinkers that influence kamu lately
aside from n kard and Simone VY I don't
know that Simone VY influenced him much
what are others known to have influenced
them if you
know um well you know uh you can look at
MIT of
Copus and see who he's engaging there I
mean he talks about
Kafka um dovi plays a major role kamu
liked dovi so much that he actually uh
adapted the demons slash the possessed
into a play that he he put on you know
um kamu also read ancient thinkers you
know so he he you know he he knew uh
some Plato and Aristotle and and people
like that and the stoics right and
epicurus I mean he talks he talks at the
very beginning of the Rebel about uh
lucretius and how lucretius is is making
epicurus into like
a a savior figure and how different that
is from epicurus's own writings so you
know classical Antiquity is is quite
important
uh for him obviously he's G to have
engaged you know dayart because you had
to read dayart as a French person um
there's no way around it he doesn't
really talk about him much because he
doesn't find him all that relevant um
but you know it's there's there's plenty
of of thinkers and interestingly you
know there some of them are people who
really deserve to be read more and
aren't being so because they're you know
they're they're looked at as not that
important but Lev shest is somebody who
kamu actually read and he wasn't reading
Athens and Jerusalem the one book that
people read these days he was reading
the early stuff where shesto is drawing
connections between n and Tolstoy and
dostoevski and doing his own thing as as
well so I would say you know uh reading
those sorts of people you'll also you
notice if you if you read um uh the uh
the rebel there's a whole bunch of
people who he's engaging and examining
like Andre Jed right or
um uh Mary dad right uh people who are
kind of luminary literary figures and
kamu is not like he's not being
influenced by them like in the sense of
like taking thoughts from them but he's
examining their points of view and
engaging with
them S car says do you think the vault
and discreet applications of modern
Marxism stems from trying to read Marx
without a continental
Foundation no I I um I don't think that
you have to have a continental
foundation and I don't even know what
the hell that would mean um that's
probably some jargon that somebody came
up with in some secondary lit thing I
mean if you mean like reading Hegel it
became quite popular to say well you
want to understand Marx you got to read
Hegel but then nobody could agree upon
what exactly Marx was taking from Hegel
and what he was getting wrong there
isn't any consensus in Continental
philosophy about that
and I think that you can read a figure
uh on their own and you can also read
them with other
people um and those you know those can
complement each other I
mean I I always want to get away from
this well you've got to have read this
before you can understand this before
you can understand this kind of
hermeneutics because th those tend to be
like the province of of the elites and
there's something a little weird about
um wanting to like explain Marx from
that kind of you know you you you
absolutely must have the proper
Foundation perspective at least in my
view right and I don't have a dog in
that fight because I'm not a Marxist you
know so all right um
Orville when studying philosophy do you
ever run into a situation where you feel
like there's something significant about
a philosopher idea that nobody discusses
and you can't figure out
why uh yeah but sometimes that's you
know that's actually wrong I mean if you
have a if you have a feeling that
there's there's an idea you got to be
able to identify what is significant
about a philosopher idea and then you
have to actually like find out whether
people are talking about it and one of
the tropes that happens over and over
again in philosophy is I have discovered
this great truth that about you know
haiger or about Aristotle that nobody
else has ever said and then you do a
review of the secondary literature and
you find out that some guy in 1807
actually wrote an article about it and
articulated your idea your new idea in
ways way better than you have you know I
mean I did that myself when I wrote my
Master's thesis on um H's passive
synthesis lectures and the constitution
of language I was bringing in diser and
other you know uh uh people from
phenomenology to say that holl's got a
really great structure here for
understanding how language works but we
need to bring in structural Linguistics
as well and other analyses of language
and then uh about a year later I'd
already read dered da on grammatology by
then but then somebody was like oh if
you like that you should read speech and
phenomena and then I discovered that IID
basically reinvented the wheel that Dara
had been there first you not exactly
doing the same thing that I was doing
but close enough right so this happens
quite often so it's important to figure
out whether whether it really is
something that nobody discusses or it's
nobody that the circles that you're in
discusses right and this is one of the
joys of uh studying philosophy as you
can find out holy crap there's a lot of
smart people out there in the field and
there have been for Millennia discussing
cool stuff you
know uh ree when you were young in your
early 20s did you ever feel lost perhaps
like no one understood you or your
interests if so any advice on that
matter for a similar person yeah I mean
I had that feeling uh at various points
in my
life um you know studying
philosophy uh in a school where there
were very few
Majors um wasn't the most uh conducive
to feeling like you're in in with a
group especially when people you know
they'll humor you for a while but then
they don't they don't want to hear you
talking about that stuff too much and
especially if you're trying to like live
out a life in accordance with it um you
know and I've felt lonely like that in
other situations as well um and it comes
and it goes and you know fortunately
these days it's not like the pre interet
where boy if you lived in a small town
and or you know you were on a small
college campus and nobody's into what
you're into you're kind of screwed right
you better find some people you can read
that
have some some interest in what you're
you're interested in I mean now you can
reach out and find anything you're
interested in you can probably find some
group and it may the engagements may be
superficial but you can find connections
all over the place we're we're kind of
fortunate in in that sense these
days right um it also makes us more
vulnerable in in certain ways to
exploitation and you know
problems that that arise but so um
advice on that matter I mean one thing
would be you can say that however and
this can apply to many things however
you happen to be feeling right now and
whatever thoughts are going along with
that
feeling um it's a good chance that the
sort of like
universalization of them is probably
going to be off base so here's a great
example you have a you you're in a a
deep uh romantic relationship you're
together with
somebody and it goes south and then you
um you know you break up and maybe you
try to get back together and then it's
still it's clear that it's not going to
work and you're like man I'm never gonna
find somebody who loves me like that
again I'm never gonna be able to love
again and open myself up to another
person and be vulnerable like that that
you know where how is this ever going to
happen oh my life has ended I'm screwed
I better go join a monastery or
something well you know it may feel like
that and you're probably if you jump
right into another relationship as they
used to call them rebound relationships
that's probably not going to go great um
but there's no reason to think that two
years down the line you can't meet
somebody just as good and more
compatible or that maybe you haven't
learned some
lessons in this this debacle of a
relationship that you can apply in a
later relationship to maybe not screw it
up to the same degree right we often
feel things that are locally valid but
not globally valid you could say so
reminding yourself of that can maybe
Inspire some uh some hope
right uh Ellie says what gives you hope
for the future of the United States
given its current
State um I don't really have a lot of
Hope for the United States given its
current state I think that
we um you know much like we've seen
previous um
superpowers are probably kind of screwed
you know um the British Empire at one
time they thought that was going to last
forever um you know at one time the
French were on top of the world you know
they were the big badasses that everyone
was a afraid of militarily I know a lot
of people like to joke about French and
surrenders and stuff like that but I
mean they've won more Wars than they've
lost throughout their history and if you
ever go through lonv valed it is quite
an experience if you are a soldier you
know
um we we have this really you know
messed
up uh economy political system society
that is rotten in a lot of ways and you
know we got like 40% of the people
willing to vote in somebody basically on
the on the basis of you know tough guy
cruelty who is a moral degenerate of
like the highest order and and they're
willing to like you know buy into some
crazy cognitive bias that makes him the
anointed of God that's a terrible sign
for things we have increasing levels of
violence um we have we're going
backwards when it comes to acknowledging
the rights of certain people within our
society and you know whether it's people
in the center or on the left or the
right very few people are willing to
like do real work and make sacrifices
and you know put themselves through the
difficult stuff of sticking to things um
and it's not a generational thing it's
not like the greatest Generation were
were actually great I mean a lot of them
were terrible people when you go back to
it same thing with the Boomers same
thing with my generation of Generation X
there's no one single like oh it was
really great back then but we had more
stable configurations I mean things are
very very hard nowadays for Young People
by comparison to what it was like for me
as a young person in the
1990s you know um and I don't see that
improving I I don't think we can get
things done we're facing huge
huge crises including global climate
change now here's the one thing I'm
optimistic about the places where the
people are the craziest on the whole are
going to be so screwed by global climate
change uh and this area you know the
Midwest we're actually gonna be okay
because we got these massive Inland Seas
we call the Great Lakes um you know it's
not that hot here the way it's going to
be down in in Texas and you know uh
Florida and places like that where the
the costs of you know just keeping
things Liva cool are going to go
massively up and uh they' they're
running out of water uh and they're
polluting the hell out of their their
you know environment and they've got
unstable electrical grids and we could
go on and on and on this area is going
to be relatively stable what we're going
to have to figure out what to do with
all these all these damn immigrants you
know from the places that are like super
anti-immigration coming up here as
refugees because of the climate and
environment that they've you know
allowed to be devastated in in the
coming decades but that doesn't make me
super optimistic because I don't know
what we're going to do with these people
you know and I think that you know maybe
our time in the sun is is done I mean
what I am optimistic about is
civilization is not the United States
you know you could be Augustine of hippo
and see the decline of Rome and you know
still contribute to world culture the
way that he did even though his Society
went under and that's pretty much what
I'm hoping I'll be able to do you know
all right vegan sports bar are there any
ethical considerations around spectacle
sporting events like the Super Bowl that
interest you I like the game but I find
the whole Enterprise to be extoling the
excesses of capitalism yeah I mean
you're thinking about like the
advertising right um I mean I don't
actually watch the Super Bowl unless a
team that I particularly like is playing
and you know if the Packers had managed
to thread the needle and make it through
the games that they had to play which
would have been you know uh they'd have
to win against the 49ers and they'd have
to beat the Lions and they were going i'
I'd watch it you know just as I did when
we uh went to the Super Bowl and played
the uh uh Ste dealers many years back
and I went to a party and we threw the
ball around and each of us brought a dis
dish to P pass and you know drank some
beer and watched the game and I got to
cheer because I was one of the few
Packers fans there I mean you can do
that without like allowing yourself to
be seduced by all the advertising I
think it's possibility for us isn't it
um do you have I mean if you're going to
uh decry anything that involves the
excesses of capitalism there's not an
awful lot you can be involved in these
days uh you can't use social media
because you're constantly being served
targeted ads um so I I think you know
you can be critical of stuff but that
doesn't mean that you have to like
puritanically um disengage from it you
know but you don't have to endorse it
either I mean you may notice that I have
recently you know one of the things that
happens with NFI stuff is they're
constantly pushing sports betting which
I think is just disgusting and I think
that these celebrities who take money
and sign on for it they're basically you
know as bad as people who would be
pushing heroin um and I've said so but I
mean does that mean I have to like you
know um refuse to watch things because
of that I I don't I don't think we have
that obligation you
know all right uh Muhammad can we
consider political philosophy as part of
moral philosophy or both should be
separate why would you do either of
those um I mean separate they overlap to
some degree you know Aristotle's nicoman
ethics Begins by saying okay now we go
on to the politics you know um and the
politics refers to ethical matters um
they're you know kind of interconnected
uh if you want to call moral
philosophy uh a broader field then
you're probably going to call ethics you
know a subdivision of moral philosophy
and politics or political philosophy
that uh we often talk about value fields
and we lump Aesthetics or or philosophy
of Art and ethics and political social
political philosophy under those but I
mean there's so many interconnections
between these right
so black prairie I haven't read much
primary text from front to back I've
read a bit from a lot of sources I feel
a bit behind compared to my class
classmates who claim to have finished
plenty should I feel inferior okay so
this is a great question no there's no
reason why you should feel inferior
because you have no idea whether your
classmates are actually lying about that
sort of thing you have no idea what
reading means for them a lot of people
claim to have read books but what
they've done is skimm them or speed read
them and they haven't really assimilated
that and um even let's assume that your
classmates have read more primary texts
than you um
it you know it's not as if you're in a
race right
um what matters is what you've actually
learned and retained from the text and
what you can do with them and I I put in
my social media uh last week or maybe
the week before a kind of funny remark
that somebody made about me back in
graduate school it was my my best friend
at the time and he said uh Greg hasn't
really read many books books but he's
really read the crap out of them the
ones that he has right so you know
there's there's breadth of reading
there's depth of reading there's there's
different ways to um to look at this but
it's it's not a competition right there
are no metrics for this sort of thing so
you shouldn't feel inferior because to
feel inferior you've got to have some
point of comparison that actually is
based in something all right vegan
sports bars got another question did you
ever get into literary modernism would
you consider uh falkner's the sound and
the fury to be a text with aura like
what I've talked about in my my video uh
a quick take video on that and by text
with aura I mean text that people love
to talk about love to have on their
shelves don't actually read just read
bits of but constantly reference like
hegel's phenomenology of spirit or Nick
Lans Fang numina or stuff like that um
would fall is the sound and the fury be
a text like that I mean not in the
circles that I move in I don't think
there's enough people who actually brag
about or refer to Falkner in that way I
would say that James Joyce's Ulisses is
is a text like that you know um did I
get into literary modernism how could I
not I mean a lot of the literary
modernism is this massive umbrella thing
that includes all sorts of other
stuff so it could be speculative fiction
like corge Lou boris's works it could be
um you know existentialist Literature
Like France Kafka uh or Raina Maria R
you know so sure I mean I I got into it
but I didn't I didn't read people
because they were
modernists um if that's what you're
asking
so all right uh DED says what's your
opinion on goder he a guy who's
interesting worth reading uh haven't
read anything of him for quite a while
but it's not because he's not
interesting um John favorites Beatles
song I don't know I'm not a real fan of
The
Beatles uh so I'm gonna pass on that
iset a big fan of tulle not a big fan
you know I like I like some of their
stuff uh listen to them a lot in the
90s but um that's when they were you
know pretty new and
stuff um Tom how would you describe or
character categorize the philosophy by
which Donald Trump lives his life I mean
he's I wouldn't even dignify it by
calling it a philosophy it's basically
you know just being an exploiter lying
about stuff it's you know kind of a
guaranteed train wreck that exploits
other people and you know provides us
with a negative
example um oh laps Continuum ever fallen
into any philosophical blind alleys for
a while and wished you
hadn't wished I hadn't no um but I've
certainly fallen into some philosophical
blind alleys the whole logicist project
of thinking that we could ultimately
reduce everything to you know
mathematized functions or data which
then we could like you know be
completely clear about
that was that was a thing that a lot of
people lived through I mean Russell
lived through that whad lived through
that the prinkipia Mathematica right
Vicken Stein his early stuff is like
that and that's why he rejects it in his
later stuff
um I got I got into that when I was a
college student in a math and philosophy
major doing lots and lots of work in the
foundations of mathematics and languages
and and uh
logic it wasn't a complete waste of time
even though I don't do anything with
that anymore right um but it was a blind
alley you could
say uh Tom does the discovery of Charles
Darwin affect the way you do philosophy
no I don't think about Darwin at all um
so all right uh Orville what was Greek
culture like in the time of Socrates and
Plato was it an immoral might makes
right culture or honor culture like
their mythology or Homer it was neither
uh cultures are always uh a mix of stuff
right and they offer different
possibilities for people and cultures
are also evolving and and changing so it
wasn't it wasn't any of those things
exclusively it was I mean you can say
this about Athens it offered the
possibility for um people like Plato to
emerge and and live in Socrates um and
and criticize that Society from within
you
know um Jake have you read any
contemporary philosophical fiction you
would recommend I'm not sure what
philosophical fiction is you mean like
more kind of
highbrow philosophy is built into it I
mean I do this whole world's of
speculative fiction series and U there
are quite a few of these authors and
series that do work with philosophically
ideas you know Stephen Erikson's Meson
books that I've you know done two
sessions on the one I'm doing for for
this um upcoming uh session on James
Kennedy's dare to know and Bride of the
tornado his stuff is pretty
philosophical he's studied philosophy
and we've had conversations about it um
you know uh there there's lots of of
authors that are in that Series where we
talk about their their uh stuff by caml
Monk have you read infinite J nope and I
don't ever plan to it doesn't sound like
something I'd really be interested in
devoting my time to um you know uh I've
read I've read a a bit of of his stuff
but nothing that turns me
on uh Tom conservatives speak a lot
about Liberty is that just a cynical
pretext by which they promote the rule
of rich people over non-rich people uh
yes and no um conservatives in America
and I'm not going to speak for
conservatives everywhere and I'm going
to say conservatives in America right
now because conservatives in the present
don't look I think that conservatives in
the time that I grew up and even
identified as a conservative for a while
would look at those present day ones and
they'd be like you're not a conservative
you're just a scumbag you know um you
haven't conserved conservativism um
because if you did you wouldn't be
saying all the stuff that you're saying
and doing all the things that you're
saying I think that it is basically used
as a a uh pretext for a lot of stuff and
some sometimes it is you know rich
people have suckered non-rich people
into basically buying their [__] and
you know allowing them to exploit
Society uh a lot of it's about cruelty
these days the the opportunity to say
screw you to people who are weaker than
you and you don't have to be rich to do
that as a matter of fact that's one of
the consolations of the everybody else
and that's one of the worst things about
it and then there's you know crazy
people there's a lot of crazy people who
identify as conservatives these days and
if you actually could like open up their
head and peer inside it would be just a
a hot mess and the word Liberty bounces
around inside of there uh we have a
Supreme Court Justice here in Wisconsin
who's like that who you know when we had
a you know there's an attempt to have
like a mask mandate she call it's
tyranny you're interfering with our
Liberty and you're like Jesus calm down
you know um a lot of people have very
very weird
emotional complexes now about this word
Liberty all right
um well we got about nine minutes left
so I'm gonna try to pick people who we
haven't already heard
from um Tong wo in a previous AMA you
mentioned you're skeptical by about The
Radical Orthodoxy project what do you
find problematic about their approach to
newv Val Tey that's a big question I
mean I I'm not skeptical I just don't
think that they're particularly
interesting they've been around for a
long time the last time I actually
engaged them would be the early 2000s
when they were like the hot new thing
right and I met Philip blonde and I you
know got to hear John Milbank speak and
I met Graham Ward and and people like
that and reviewed their Works um you
know John mil Banks is a big fan of
Maurice Blondell in Theology and social
theory Blondell isn't newel theology
he's like one of the inspirers of that
and he has a lot of great things to say
about Blondell which unfortunately are a
misreading of Blondell you know uh I
think that they do sloppy work and I
just don't find them interesting you
know I don't find them to be worth
engaging um
Chandler says I'm a new subscriber have
you read much of Charles Taylor
particularly his book sources of the
self read it way back in graduate school
haven't read it much other than like
little snatches of it since then you
know Taylor's an interesting fellow um I
just never found his work all that
compelling um you know somebody who's
kind of in the same sphere as Alistar
McIntyre I like his his stuff a lot
better you
know um
let's see
here Tony James do you see Universal
human rights is inherent in us at Birth
or bestowed by a Creator or as a social
construct
yep all of the
above um it's not an exclusive thing
let's see
here
[Music]
um greo beino what's your take on
epicurian politics especially in light
of later epicureans like Brutus choosing
not to stay out of them uh Brutus wasn't
an epican as far as I know as a matter
of fact the one guy who Brutus is really
well known for killing is Julius Caesar
who was usually targeted as being an
epicurian there isn't a lot of epican
politics out there certainly not in the
early ancient
period um you you'd really have to go to
like enlightenment
figures to find people explicitly
epicurian laying out uh political
Theory um so I mean there's not much to
engage with
there um I'm not sure how to read the
cilic uh thing have you read the
McIntyre intellectual biography by Emil
peros saine no I I don't really read a
lot of stuff like that if I you know I
read the primary text most ly I'm not I
read you know oliv a blanchett's
intellectual biography on Blondell
because I was asked to review it and I
like all of a Blanchette and I did learn
some things in the process but I mean I
studied under McIntyre and and uh i'
I've read most of all the things that
he's written so I kind of don't need an
intellectual biography of
him uh Fred Schmidt can you be gay and a
Catholic do you have to be celibate I
understand if you are comfortable
answering this question
well I'm not a theologian so I I kind of
you know kind of doesn't matter yeah of
course you can I mean you can be all
sorts of things and be a Catholic I mean
it's ridicul this this like oh can you
cross this line or cross this line that
ain't how human life works you know I
mean there's gay people all over the
world you know can you be gay and be a
Muslim yeah you can you better kind of
keep it to yourself or you're going to
get in trouble right but that's a
Prudential matter right right so that's
what I would say about that
um let's see who else do we have that we
haven't heard
from
um Luke mockery artificial intelligence
doesn't exist not a question but just a
a statement which I actually agree with
uh I think that artificial intelligence
at least at this point in time is merely
a metaphor that people love to kick
around and then forget that it's a
metaphor right um I haven't seen
anything in what people want to call
artificial
intelligence that makes me say yes this
is genuine intelligence or you know
another thing that's a complete uh
metaphor to machine learning the what's
going on is not the same thing as
learning or being trained or stuff like
that I kind of wish we had a different
vocabulary that wasn't quite so
metaphorical for this stuff and then
people would be less prone to making all
sorts of bad decisions and inferences on
the basis of these these optimistic and
sometimes pessimistic metaphors like oh
the artificial intelligence is out to
get me skynets after me right you know
so you can go either way with it Corey
doctor have had a really really great
article that came out re recently and
about AI hype and he pointed out that
like you know people are making
decisions based on this and it turns out
that the things that they think are so
intelligent that they can replace their
employees with don't work most of the
time and then you got to hire backend
employees to do even more work you know
so that that's kind of a interesting
thing
um let's see who else haven't we heard
from um John asked have you heard of the
work of Roger halum I I haven't but you
know it doesn't mean anything that I
haven't heard of somebody because
there's for every one person I've heard
of there's thousands of people I haven't
heard of we're we're just you know
that's that's the state of our culture
at this point in time
right
um Julia says uh could you please
suggest a book to better understand what
is true love to a male regarding right
choice of husband and a book on true
purpose and meaning of life well I don't
think that true love uh is different for
men and women fundamentally I I sort of
fall into you know thinkers like Raina
Maria rke or you know um Mary walstone
craft who or you know the stoics who
think that men and women are not as
fundamentally different as people make
them out to be and that that's kind of a
mistake and and a social Dynamic that
gets that reinforces itself um that said
um one book that I I I really think is
and a thinker who I think is quite good
on this issue is uh detri Von
hildenbrand he's got a book on marriage
and you know traditionally you know
Dietrich Von hildenbrand student of mock
shayer uh Catholic thinker uh
phenomenologist very important was
influential uh as was shayer on on John
Paul II um so anyway you know there's
there's often been this thing this this
wrongheaded idea that what is sex for
it's for procreation you know and um
that's the main point and then
everything else is either an add-on or a
seduction or something like that right
and if you actually look at what um you
know another book I'll recommend monks
on marriage by jacqu L Clair because
he's looking at all this monastic
literature and the monks are not so
interested in reproduction they're
interested in mut ual love between
people you know something that by the
way ansom was a great counselor about
ansom of Canterbury Mantic
thinker um and so you know there's this
like aspect of love in return
redare uh in in Latin that's Central
there and these monks are drawing that
by the way also from Sena and Cicero and
people like that so there's a classic
tradition as
well but what about pleasure what about
that you know that realm desire and
pleasure Dietrich Von hilden brand is
good and you know for pointing out that
this is an integral part of coupled
relationships if that's lacking
something fundamental is missing you
know it isn't just about having sex
every once in a while to make some
babies and will will let you get away
with having a little fun no that is part
of an actual healthy love coupled
relation relationship you know so
um anyway I I I don't remember the the
title of the book off hand but if you
just Google detri Von hilden brand
marriage that that'll come up um
emergence is a means of participation do
you have any opinions on the work of
Elizabeth
ancom I like reading her um sometimes I
find her you know quite
insightful I think that um the whole
Narrative of the Revival virtue ethics
thing is kind of BS uh virtue ethics
never went away except in very parochial
academic analytic philosophy people were
still using these ideas in other areas
of philosophy Eve Simone wrote a
wonderful book on the nature of virtue
around the same time that these supposed
virtue ethicist were Reviving it in in
English circles so but you know she's
she's well worth worth checking out
um let's see
[Music]
um find a good one to go out
on
um a lot of back and forth here oh okay
we'll we'll do this so Tom a stray cat
that lives entirely outdoor
doors visits me daily it begs to be
picked up and petted so I do but do I
risk catching fleas or ticks parasites
fleas rabies by doing this I don't think
so I mean fleas are more interested in
other hairy creatures so unless you're
like you know rubbing the cat against
your your um chest hair or something
like that probably not going to be a big
deal uh ticks takes a while for a tick
to go somewhere uh if you think the
cat's rabid I
mean that's the only condition under
which you're going to catch that so
doubt it
um let's
see
um all right so we got another good one
that's kind of a silly one um to go out
on
um okay here we go from
aligator if you were going through a
rough patch in life and someone gave you
a book on transactional analysis to help
you out how would you feel about that
gift well I would feel if you're talking
about me it's nice that I got this book
I might read it um I've already read
about transactional analysis so I don't
see how that would help me and I can
take it to the used bookstore and get a
little money for it you know so maybe
I'll buy myself a a coffee or a candy
bar with what they they gave me um
because I I don't know that um that's
going to be that helpful for you you
probably so more serious answer you
probably want to ask them okay what am I
supposed to get out of this why did you
give me this book what do you have in
mind for me and then you can start a
conversation with them and that could
perhaps be a better more useful gift for
you I would say maybe you can uh you
know get something out of that um and
form a deeper friendship or you can
figure out whether they they're not
really being that helpful for you in
which case maybe you don't want to be
that involved with them so all right
well I'm going to bring this to a close
thanks for all of your questions and uh
another good session hope uh you uh
enjoyed it got a lot of events coming up
this month mostly on Saturdays as well
as uh a new online class that is
starting on stoicism the cardinal
virtues there's a link to it in the
video description if you're
interested and uh yeah we we do these
every month um if you want to see any of
the old ones where I talk about maybe
some of the things that people were
asking about like Jordan Peterson
there's a whole playlist that you can go
to so I will see all of you Somewhere In
The Ether and uh talk to you
later